il va faire chaud ce week end à mort par
un festival musical chaud l'hiver fait
son grand retour et 1er et 2 mars café
de la plage au programme deux soirées
thématiques confiée exclusivement
musiciens locaux la première aux
vibrations groove hip hop et reggae la
seconde fut musclée sonorités rock
ce traditionnel rendez vous hivernal de
maurepas est également l'occasion de
découvrir le nouveau bâtiment après un
an et demi de travaux 900 mètres carrés
d'espacé au total avec une deuxième
salle de spectacle voilà de quoi réjouir
les groupes heavy noah qui se produiront
ce week end les airs cas système que
nous avons suivis pendant leurs
répétitions nous livrent leurs
impressions
ça a beaucoup changé là nous on était un
peu à c'est un peu notre maison le café
de la plage c'est là qu'on a vraiment
fait nos premières scènes mais c'est
vrai que là matos tout neuf donc
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de potentiel
dans la salle toujours la même équipe
qui est qui connaît enfin que nous on
connaît bien et où nous que c'est quand
même la maison s'arrête la maison mais
en mieux je crois parce que là il ya
l'air d'avoir l'acoustique vraiment
super sympa la configuration de la salle
moins en longueur plus en largeur c'est
quand même c'est quand même mieux
l'entrée est gratuite cependant une
réservation obligatoire auprès de la
structure guise de bienvenue un cocktail
sera offert jusqu'à 21h30